la rénovation énergétique permet
d'améliorer l'efficacité du logement sur
le plan thermique
ça va consister à l'isoler mieux les
murs renouveler l'air faire en sorte que
la maison soit plus économe et surtout
plus confortable ça consiste à à venir a
ajouté un isolant ou au mur existant et
ensuite venir le recouvrir avec une
protection qui va être soit un enduit
soit un bardage
ce sont des échantillons isolation par
l'extérieur tout d'abord avec du
polystyrène de la laine de roche et la
fibre de bois
on va ensuite appliquer une couche de
sous enduit une couche de fibre de verre
de toile et ensuite on va venir donc
faire le ravalement
[Musique]